You can say whatever.
Yeah.
Why am I nervous? I don't
know. I'm nervous right out.
Ooh,
my name is patty and I am pro life.
I had two abortions.
I know what happens to the emotional
and psychological part of women.
My name is John and I'm pro choice or the
six years of the planned parenthood of
golden gate.
My name is Marie and I am pro life and
I help him in reverse their abortion and
once they've started them
if they would like to do so.
All right.
All [inaudible].
Hi Sports is the question.
Do you do this thing?
Is it tight?
No,
don't do it.
Well I'm the only one.
Oh well sandwiches.
Just something between two pieces
of bread and that's what hot dog is.
I disagree
and sandwiches, two
pieces of bread. Right.
But a hot dog bun isn't two pieces
of bread does its own thing.
And just the way it's Eaton was if
you had a hot dog bun and you put um,
like Deli meats in there, would that
be still up? Would it be a sandwich?
That would still be a hot dog though
still, right? I mean, it's like, oh, okay,
are we going to solve
next?
Sometimes I have a question around frozen.
Oh,
right.
Yeah. Because the other person's
perspective and you're like, okay,
that makes sense. Yeah. No,
I think I questioned mine often because
I could imagine that if I wasn't living
my life based on my Christianity,
um,
I would want women to
have that choice as well.
I used to be a pro life feminist really,
until I had an abortion.
Actually I had two and after
I realized what I had done,
I knew I had made the biggest mistake
in my life. I realized that it was,
it wasn't my,
I shouldn't be taking the life of a child.
So after that,
I struggled with it for 35
years with my abortions.
And so I have no doubts.
I am all the way pro pro life.
But I believe fundamentally that the
woman should have that right to make the
decision. And if I've never been
anybody, anybody's pro abortion,
and oftentimes they don't have good
choices and they're picking the lesser of
the bad choices.
Yeah. I just feel like, uh, my, I'm
very certain of my views because,
uh, I want to respect that
everyone has that option. Um,
and I think that if you take that away,
you in danger children more than if
you allow them to make that choice for
themselves. So, but she, uh,
we'll make and choose for herself,
but she doesn't have the right to choose
for someone else because if a child is
inconvenient as a toddler, are you
going to kill that child as a toddler?
And then they were talking about a
completely different thing knowing that
science,
we're talking science and I'm saying
like a lot of times women have to have
abortions because of medical reasons.
That's like a lot of time time.
Oh,
you got us right in the thick of it.
Next,
I know of the,
my sister had an abortion.
Um,
almost two years ago I found out I was
pregnant and had an abortion forced on me
by a man twice my age
who made a ton of money.
And I felt like I had no other
choice if I wasn't a Christian.
And if I didn't believe
the things that I believed,
I would be pro choice like
100% but at the end of the day,
like to my core,
I believe that all human life is
so sacred and it's not our choice.
It's never been our choice.
I realize that I shouldn't have had that
choice because I was choosing life and
death over another human being.
It's taking alive.
But I do understand, definitely
understand where you guys came from.
The only difference we have is when
the fetus becomes a human life.
If that's an and B, then my
tonsils in the movies, I think
it's a scary gray area. And in
the Bible you did say, you know,
I don't know what part of Christianity,
but Jesus says,
before I formed you in your mother's womb,
I knew you and not a sparrow falls
from the sky without my knowing.
I feel like I really respect
you and your faith. I respect,
respect that that's your feeling
and that you all feel that way.
But I also feel like, um, one can
feel that way regardless of the Bible,
regardless of Christianity. You
know, it's one of those things that
okay
happens and has happened
actually for decades, you know,
for a while and people make that
decision and it is their decision.
They make that decision for whatever
reasons. You know, I mean again, you,
you help people who have taken a pill
first then change their mind and I think
that's great, but if you have one and
you feel regretful, then deal with it.
If you have, when you don't really feel
regretful or you feel like it really,
truly was the best decision for you,
then that's what happens.
And I just think we all know people that,
or I don't,
I just don't feel like we have any
right to, to force a particular way.
And you know, I think it's great to,
to try to just be open, you know?
Okay.
Pretty judge,
I believe.
Hey guys,
it's been a long time.
I think we all feel that way because,
because
it's an emotional,
a very emotional topic.
I've actually been verbally attacked
by a lot of the pro choice people.
You know about what I went
through with the regret,
the alcoholism and all of that
stuff that tied into the abortion
for me.
It's something that Maria said a little
bit while ago about her Christian faith
and implicit in that, is it someone
whose approach choices and Christian,
I was raised a Roman Catholic.
I consider myself a Christian.
I don't believe that there's anything
in Christianity as I understand it,
that requires me to believe
that abortion is murder.
I grew up in a Christian home.
My mom's a pastor,
but they also respect that they know
that it's my ultimate decision and they
know that what it is I'm going to do well,
I'm going to choose for my life.
They don't have control over and that
I am an adult sometimes in the argument
between the two sides. There's a lack
of respect for the fact that like,
I don't have to agree with you.
You live your life the way that you want
to and I'll leave it the way I want you
as long as you're not stopping.
Sorry you guys.
I have two kids. One a son who's 30. Uh,
and then a daughter who is 28.
I have one son who is 36.
He's adopted.
I couldn't have children biologically.
I convinced the doctor to give me a
Tubal ligation because I didn't feel I
punished myself for having the abortions.
Okay.
I have a daughter,
she's a year old and she's in heaven.
To me, it, my experience at planned
parenthood was everybody got to kids.
And the, the slogan, if you will,
of planned parenthood was no
child, unwanted child, not pad.
We wanted our children and
that's why we chose to have them.
What about all the people that would
gladly take care of that child that cannot
have a pregnancy to save their life?
Well, because the woman
has to, it has to go
nine months for a whole life
that a child could have.
Um, I think one of the things that
I immediately reacted is that,
okay, nine months, whatever.
But there are so many children,
not just in America but the world over
that don't have loving parents that are
not in a loving situation, that
are not cared for, fed, clothed,
loved.
And I,
and I think that is the most important
thing to care about our children because
they are our future. So the child in
the womb has no value whatsoever. No,
I don't think so at all. I'm not saying
that I never said, I'm just asking,
just saying that to me that's
unclear whether it's you know,
this or that or this or that.
And despite the fact that you say there
are people out there that want to adopt
this child or want to
take care of this child,
there are still so many that are not.
And that's, I don't think that wrong.
Makes this right though.
I understand that. I'm not
saying that I'm only, I'm only,
I'm only responding to your comments
about my, my view is I don't,
I don't personally want to have kids.
I want to adopt all my children
because of that reason.
And because I live with a family that
took me in when my family didn't want me.
And so I understand that one,
the foster system and
adoption is not that easy.
And if we're making it about taking
care of the child, yeah, let's do that.
Let's take care of the children.
But we need to make sure that there
are opportunities in place for all the
children to be successful so that that
child has a world that co to come into
you.
It's actually going to be good to it
because we don't live in that world right
now. We don't offer those
things to our children.
We should talk a lot of the people
that came from a ton of adversity,
you've now made it in this world
who live talking about that.
We're not talking about the success
cannot be about people that I am a kid,
so to day they do not. And they're
worth that worth, in my opinion,
is exactly equal to a 20 week baby and
totally understand and I respect that.
I'm only saying, my only comment was
I feel like it's unfair to be like,
well, blah, blah blah in nine months.
Why can't you just have a kid for nine
months? And they give it up. Oh, cool.
It is getting cooler in here though,
isn't it?
Yeah.
Um,
I wasn't expecting to hear some of the
stories about people's lives and their
experiences, um, who've had abortions.
And like I can only,
I can only imagine the pain that is
associated to making that decision.
And I have a lot of compassion and
sympathy for people who go through that.
Um,
I wasn't expecting,
I wasn't expecting it to
be as calm as it was. Um,
I think that there were moments,
but I think for the most part we
were respectful each other. And,
um, I still think that you
guys are awesome people.
I the outside of this situation,
okay.
I wasn't surprised at how this has
gone because when we were all talking
outside,
it didn't make any difference who's
side was on whose side and we,
and we all bonded right away.
You know,
sometime you are levels got a
little bit raised, but you know,
why were we all respect each other?
No matter what you do, you've,
you've heard all the arguments.
There's not going to be one argument
where you're like, oh my gosh,
I just changed my mind. No,
it's never going to, you know,
people are who they are and it usually
takes a certain situation happening,
but I think it's healthy to
have the dialogue. I think
it doesn't happen enough.
It happens too much behind our computers.
Oh, okay. Cool.
Sorry,
dogs.
It was great to me.
Yeah.